saint martin est sans aucun doute un des
saints patrons les plus populaires au
monde et pourtant c'est précisément là
où repose son tombeau en france qu'on
semble le moins le connaître il y avait
effectivement des pays où la tradition
de saint martin est fortement ancrée et
fêter notamment tout le monde germanique
ça c'est absolument absolument certain
l'autriche la hongrie mais aussi
l'italie et l'espagne autres pays
importants du culte martinien
l'argentine d'où est originaire le pape
françois il a lui-même été évêque de
buenos aires qui a pour patron saint
martin de tours invité officiellement
par la mairie et par monseigneur
aubertin il est donc attendu à tour mais
sans aucune certitude mais si la venue
du pape peut bien sûr attirer encore
plus de monde les pèlerins sont tout de
même attendus nombreux il ya un certain
nombre de diocèses à l'ambassade
d'allemagne route qui comptent venir
avec plusieurs centaines de personnes et
ça ça s'organise aussi au niveau
hébergement etc bien sûr on travaille en
lien avec
beaucoup de structures notamment la
structure départementale 10 au dessus du
tourisme impossible de célébrer le
jubilé de saint-martin sans sa statue au
sommet de la basilique il faudra donc la
rénovation soient terminés d'ici là où
envisager un plan b parce qu'ils font
mais lui ne le statut en résine est ce
qu'il faut voilà
tout le monde est en train de réfléchir
et essayer de trouver la meilleure
solution la mairie bien sûr qui est
propriétaire des bâtiments
souhaite faire tout ce qu'elle peut pour
que les la restauration soit fait le
plus rapidement possible il faudra
peut-être avant recours aussi en
complément à une souscription publique
j'en ai entendu parler 11 novembre 2015
4 juillet 2010 est un an et demi de fête
pour célébrer les 1700 ans de la
naissance de saint martin et permettre à
tous de re découvrir au delà du simple
partage du manteau celui qui fut un des
premiers évangélisateurs de la gaule